if you were questioning which infinity
stone is the most powerful out of all of
the stones you no longer have to ask
that question
thanks to Avengers infinity war visual
effects supervisor Dan D'Elia
we now know what stone is the most
powerful just a reminder to the Infinity
war blu-ray giveaway still continues all
you have to do to enter is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero the Power Stone
thanks to Dandeli o we now know that the
Power Stone is the most powerful out of
all of the Infinity stones which makes
sense it is the Power Stone
although the Power Stone had the
smallest roll out of all of the stones
in the movie dinos having already
grabbed it from Zander before the movie
even started we did get a glimpse of its
true power a couple of times in the
movie one is when it grabbed a moon out
of orbit and then threw chunks of that
moon at the Avengers that is already a
huge sign of the power stones power but
the biggest moment of all it was the
snap yes
Thanos had to collect all of the
Infinity stones before being able to
perform the snap and many fans thought
that it was actually the soul stone that
was responsible for it mainly and the
Leos team actually wanted the reality
stone or the soul stone to be the stone
that delivered the final blow
because souls cease to exist but at the
end it was the Power Stone that
delivered the final blow dandelion this
himself when talking about the snap he
said that it was the Power Stone that
was flipping them out of existence this
makes sense seeing as how in the past
the Power Stone has been used by
Celestials for the sole purpose of
devouring and wiping out entire planets
and populations also if you want to hear
my theory on how Galactus is actually
stuck inside of the Power Stone you can
check it out in the link above so it
wasn't the sole stone that was
responsible for executing the snap it
was the Power Stone but if the Power
Stone was responsible for wiping out
half of the universe perhaps the soul
stone is the key to bringing everybody
back after all the Russo brothers
themselves did say that their favorite
stone
bring to life was the soul stone when
asked on Twitter what their favorite
stone was they replied the soul stone
was the most mysterious and so the most
fun to spin a story around so who knows
what the soul stone could hold for us
and Avengers for I definitely think
along with most of the fandom I'm sure
that we will explore soul world and
Avengers 4 and that the people trapped
inside will definitely be coming back
but what are your thoughts on this what
do you think about the Power Stone being
the strongest out of all of the Infinity
stones and what do you think about the
soul stone and Avengers 4 let me know
your thoughts in the comments below and
again don't forget about our giveaway
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]